is certainly one person that represents
that to me and that's Jerry Lee Lewis
now you guys may not know who he is I
realized that on the way over but he was
one of the architects of rock and roll
he was one of the guys that changed it
from not rock and roll to rock and roll
was Jerry Lee Little Richard Chuck Berry
Fats Domino bill nailing in the comments
and Elvis Jared was like a Greek tragedy
he grew up in Ferriday Louisiana and his
family was very religious their religion
was the assembly of god they thought
everything was sinful music was sinful
you know dancing with simple clothes
women were sinful just because of
biblical things and he grew up with this
terrible I he he had two cousins one was
Mickey Gilley who became a country piano
player and the other was Jimmy Swaggart
who became a televangelist but in this
in his atmosphere of such strong
religion he nevertheless felt music in
the marrow of his bones there was
nothing he could do but make music it's
it was as if God had made him a music
person and so that he could spend his
life sitting and terrible terrible
quandary for a young dude and the fact
of being this instant performing talked
about the brooklyn fox will brook lynn
para mountain and had paramount theaters
all those three theaters were real hot
in the mid 50's and you go and you get
pressed up against the stage people
would go nuts because it was you know
last weekend there was no rock and roll
and this weekend suddenly that was
rock'n'roll it was it was a switch and
so he had a good deal of idol tree and
already a couple of passages from his
biography that will give you a little
idea about Jerry Lee if one of the lines
to his songs is these gray hairs you see
don't model jerilee and neither do these
lines
this is about Myra Gale his uh his 15
year old third life still he smelled a
sinfulness in her women had thrown
themselves on him for five years
wherever he went it seemed cheap perfume
thighs parted live and yielding as the
windblown reads of Turtle Lake had
parted first to receive whatever scrap
of garish stinking fame and glory they
might then later to receive the
grotesque Wraith of that Fame in that
glory every time he discouraged himself
in the mouth of whoredom he cursed all
women for what they had to him shown
themselves to be he turned on his wife
unable to believe her to see that she
could be any different from the rest he
accused her of adultery and he beat her
perhaps his mother often stayed with a
couple in Memphis encouraged her dear
sons accusations for she and motherhood
trusted none of Jerry leaves wives
believing that they lusted only for his
gold and she spent time seeking to
discover Myra Gale in an act of moist
indiscretion so this is this is about
his uh his drinking we're now to 1982 he
had drunken takin pills since he was a
teenager pumping piano in the Natchez
honky-tonks but he had allowed neither
the liquor nor the pills to reign over
since the death of his son however he
had grown more extreme and whiskey and
drugs were fast becoming as important a
part of his life as God and music the
booze and the pills stirred the hell
within him and made him to utter hideous
peels at times he withdrew into his own
shadow brooding upon all manner of
things abominable unutterable
worse at times you stalk them rented and
proud and follow nip events commanding
those about him as Billy allows his
minions he was the killer and he was
immortal damn to be for as long as they
were good and evil to be torn between in
agony he would sit backstage and a
thousand dank night flows and he would
know this and he would swallow more
pills and wash them down with three
fingers more of whiskey and he would
know it even more he would walk like a
man to the stage with his Churchill
cigar and one man in his water glass of
whiskey and the other and he found the
piano and sing his sinful songs and he
would beckon those before him mortals
may not heed to destruction from the
womb he would beckon them to come to
stand with him a while brink of heaven
then he would be gone into the ancient
night two more pills and more whiskey to
wear the black dogs never ceased barking
and Dawn never broke he would go there
and finally 1972 where it's far away
from the strip urging yet were at
palomino in North Hollywood a very
famous country bar a week later on jun
18 Jerry Lisa onstage at the Palomino
club in North Hollywood and he looked
into the eyes of the audience and said
Elvis killed himself over a broad took
five of them to put me into shape on him
today in his dressing room after the
show he SAT holding in his lap a half
drain port seagrams like the unloading
scepter of an ancient fading kinship
he'd ruin his cigar and gesture toward
the tape recorder that the writer had
placed before him you know one of them
things get a man killed he said man be
drinking saying something somebody take
that tape and use it against him getting
buried the time is near he said his eyes
wide as a terror regarding every more
remote that
did through the stale air of that
dressing on as if it held innumerable
demons we don't have the promise of the
next breath fire and brimstone fire
never dies the burnin never dies the
fire never quenches for the weeping
wailing gnashing of teeth is anybody
going to heaven the writer asking very
few there if you hard place to get to
Sun can't get there through Palomino
club that's for damn sure Church can't
get you to heaven religion can't get you
to heaven then he took a good long swig
change the subject even though Sonny
said there's only been four of us Al
Jolson Jimmie Rodgers Hank Williams and
Jerry Lee Lewis that's your only for
stylists that ever lived we
could write see the oval dance for Thor
what makes no damn difference rest of
these idiots is either riding
horse picking the guitar shooting
somebody in some stupid damn movie then
you took another swig and yelled next
how do you feel about people who combine
music and politics a bunch of
idiots so you don't figure on playing at
any anti-nuke benefits in the near
future hell no them all
blom all clear the hill get over it
quick just don't kill no alligators in
Louisiana I married a couple you've been
married five times now that's my
business well do you know any more about
women now than you did the first time
you've got madden yeah why are you so
obsessed with hell because Satan has
power next to God you ain't loyal the
god you must be loyal to Satan they
ain't knowing between Fame serve to
God's sin I know soon I'm going to have
to reckon with the children hands of
death